hello i'm jimmy catro you may know me  from  home economics on abc maybe my youtube  channel life according to jimmy maybe uh  the real brothers of steamie valley  either way drew asked what i'm watching  so i'm here to let you know that lately  i've been reeling shrek started with the  first one  just for nostalgia purposes rode that  one  straight into shrek 2. um  and then wrote that straight into shrek  3. i actually did not make it to shrek  four  for the uh puss and boot spin-offs  but um i really just coasted straight  through  shrek one two and then three it was  it was in the span of about 24 hours um  but you gotta love it i mean you know  you got lord farquaad  you got you got post and boots you got  donkey  it's just the soundtrack and shrek too i  mean  people sleep on that but yeah it was uh  it was a good time  that's what i've been watching thanks  for having me again i'm jenny tatro  and uh checking out on home economics  you